you could probably sit through about 10
hours of
sexuality studies women's sex and gender
studies and then this woman could go up
there and she'd say okay here's my
counterpoint
what sexual orientation i see it lets me
know he's a man
i love this woman not just race that is
causing people
some some problems it's not just this
race hustling there's also this
radical sexual politics there's a video
just came out from a spa
where a woman is going up to the manager
and complaining because the spa
has a a transgender policy and the spa
allowed a dude
to go into the women's changing room and
just strip down
in front of the the women and
the women don't want to have to see this
i don't think women and little girls
should be forced to see naked grown men
with all of the various appendages and
the staff says sorry there's nothing we
can do he says he's a woman he's a woman
you know so it's okay i just want to be
clear with you
it's okay it's okay for a man to go into
the women's section
show his penis around the other women
young little girls under age
your spa we spa condone that is that
what you're saying
like i asked it's so he so he can stay
there
he could stay there what sexual
orientation i see
it lets me know he's a man he's a man
he is a man he is not no female
i love this woman i love so what this
woman is showing by the way you can hear
the way she's speaking
is a little colloquial it's not
academic it's not fancy i suspect this
woman doesn't go to
sort of soirees at the the critical race
theory
organizations movement at harvard
college she doesn't sound like that at
all
she's speaking much more bluntly and
directly she also doesn't sound white
right we're told that the only people
who oppose these radical policies
are the white supremacists and whatever
this woman doesn't sound particularly
white to me
and she's going out there and she's
saying hey get that dude out of the
women's changing room
and the guy behind the counter says well
no you understand because of the sexual
orientation she says what about sexual
orientation
i don't see sexual orientation i see a
phallus
okay that lets me know he's a man
i love the way you know you could
probably sit through about
10 hours of of sexuality studies women's
sex and gender studies
at harvard or yale or somewhere else and
and have them try to explain to you the
meaning of the deconstruction of the
gender and then this and
that and then this woman could go up
there and she'd say okay here's my
counterpoint
i see a phallus that's that's what lets
me know that he's a man
say you know gosh we could have saved
ourselves all that time
all that jargon to just know yes that is
what lets you know that he's a man
and it it's obviously wrong to force
women and little girls to change
to strip naked in front of dudes and to
have to see
naked dudes in their changing room
that's obviously wrong and no amount of
philosophizing by these
kooks and cranks on the campuses is
going to change that
hey don't you go before you leave me a
comment leave me a let me know what you
think as long as what you think is very
very positive let me know also what you
think of my book speechless controlling
words controlling minds available now
finally
it's only been out for about three or
four days now it's one of the top books
on amazon i'm pleased to say
because all of you wonderful people have
bought the book you can get the audible
you can also get the hardcover
and you can help us stick it to the
various leftist best seller lists and
all the squishy conservatives who i go
after in this book so go check that out
leave me a comment what you think like
and subscribe
i'll see you next time
you